hey guys my name is Jess McDonald eat is
the 24th of sep tember today and you're
watching games but news first up if you
love sleeping dogs when you'll love the
sleeping dogs sequel which may or may
not be happening develop a united front
games that they'd love to make another
sleeping dogs game but their focus is
currently on free to play pc game triad
wars which they unveiled yesterday triad
wars is also set in hong kong as a part
of the sleeping dogs universe and
although it's currently pc exclusive
united front games are hoping to get it
out on every platform when asked why the
game is free-to-play producer Justin
Bullard said that the model fits the
game perfectly and if they've done the
job right gamers won't ever have to pay
to have fun if your heart is set on
sleeping dogs you can grab the
definitive edition out for xbox one ps4
and PC in October your duty advanced
warfare 4 player co-op mode has been
revealed and there's a trailer to feast
your eyes on the mode called EXO
survival includes four of you good guys
up against a whole lot more than four
bad guys some of whom appear to be max
there's a whole lot of sweet ways to
kill off enemies and look good doing it
and Kevin Spacey shouts on my authority
so you know what's the rest of the video
one side if you're into all that on my
authority laughs off the mark today and
in more futuristic FPS news titanfall
DLC is landing on Xbox one and PC
tomorrow the third expansion pack IMC
rising doesn't yet have a confirmed
release date for Xbox 360 the DLC
consists of three new maps backwater
zone 18 and sand trap IMC rising is the
third expansion to be included in the
$25 Titan full deal see pass which also
contained previously released expansions
frontiers edge and expedition we've got
the trailer for the new DLC on gamespot
if you want to check out what you're in
for ask you a question of the day let me
know if you're still playing titanfall
and its DLC maps are enough to get you
back into a day
him if you're often more news you can
check out gamespot where we've got
stories on Bryce on PC dropping
microtransactions and the implications
of Blizzard canceling tighten that is it
for me today I'll be back soon time and
place tomorrow so i hope to see them